we are here at the DC tower sandy san
diego comic-con with DC's co-publisher
gym lead and a deal how are you guys
doing doing doing very well dan is
reminding everyone that this is my 30th
consecutive Comicon a row so I actually
feel kind of ancient now but it's yes me
too you know that don't you like oh
you're right oh my god that's a lot of
time dude it's a lot of time so how is
Comic Con changed in the 30 years uh
it's changed quite a bit obviously when
we first came the publishers would have
maybe an eight-by-eight booth with like
one sign that had their logo above it
all the artists were now artists alley
and then there were dealers basically
selling comics and all bootleg VHS
copies of TV shows that were you guys
bunches yeah probably do I'm fine copies
of UFO and Batman 66 you know that's
that's how you found it back then before
the DVD era and so you know um but it
had its own charm you know mostly comics
focus mostly younger crowd mostly men
boys obviously completely different from
what it is now but uh you know it's it's
you would never have dreamt in a million
years that it would evolve and become
this so it's amazing now probably price
should talk about like rebirth some some
current stuff did you get what did you
guys think before you announced it
before you launch it cuz it's been crazy
successful so you know what listen we
caught lightning a bottle once with with
new 52 you know and that was a real roll
of the dice and we got behind it and the
full strength was of the the company got
behind it in on every level from
marketing to promotion to the sales
teams and we got it we made that a huge
success and then we thought here we are
we going to try it and basically
replicate it again within a five-year
window and it was nerve-racking you know
but you know it was way back in October
we got a sense that there was a shift in
the business we saw things fading again
sort of like it was before we launched
in 52 we knew something needed to be
done we had long meetings about how to
approach this and we realized that in
order to reconnect with our fanbase to
reconnect with that core we had to go
back and understand the core of our
characters again and get back to the
heart of what they were and what people
loved about them and what they felt was
missing but
wasn't an easy road we went out there we
did the hard sell to the fans with a
live streaming broadcast we went to the
retailer's we went to city by city to
talk to retails themselves and I'm like
to say this is just the fruition of a
lot of Labor not just on the creative
side but the full company again to get
us the point we're at right now now a
lot of your books are shipping twice a
month is so far everything going
smoothly with that no one's pulling
their hair out or anything you find to
find smoothly yeah to find here has
there been any feedback from the
creators that are like you know it's
grueling it's it's as you would imagine
it's a lot of work for all you know not
just editorial and the greatest but
production manufacturing even the people
through the solicits and the publicity
it's like you're running a double speed
all the time that said the numbers have
an interest from the readership it has
has been tremendous I mean we have issue
tues outs on the issue ones we have
really the sales on issues three and
four really kind of plateauing and not
seeing that really steep drop that you
sometimes get when you launch new series
so it's all working and I think it's
because there's just a lot of excitement
and hunger for what the storylines are
and delivering at a faster pace allows
the creators to kind of be in the
readers consciousness in their head
space more frequently I find it more
interesting with suicide squad were
actually splitting up the main story the
splitting of the book into a main story
that's by 12 or 13 pages in the backup
story 78 pages and one of the concerns
we had was like well won't that make it
feel like it's a short experience a
little fragment and it's like no because
you're going to get the second chapter
two weeks later so it's going to be more
of a roller coaster ride which is what
you would want with a book like Suicide
Squad so it really plays into the what
the books what the book stands for so I
think people are starting unlock kind of
cool things you can do with a
twice-monthly shipping and using them in
creative ways to reinforce the
storytelling and do some really
interesting creative innovative stuff
now I believe in some cases you're
seeing a more or the traits selling are
you guys going to change
like how soon you put them out or we've
changed our trade delivery right now you
won't be seeing any of the rebirth
trades until the new year until 2017 so
the trays will come quicker and also all
the trades will be released in softcover
trade softcover form first we won't be
doing a hardcover on any of our books at
the start we will be doing the land soft
cover so that way I think will be more
affordable and hopefully continue to
grow because that's where we see a lot
of our growth right now is in the in the
bookstore channel in the mass market and
we want to make sure we continue to grow
their last question is it possible to
see more Lois Lane anywhere because
they're like merchandise product because
there's not a whole lot of Lois Lane and
I know there's a huge huge fan like you
know with DC collectibles there's a book
called superwoman that has her pretty
prominently featured so that could be a
change like there's a Superman Lois
statue I think that's on the dockets
right now and you know we've looked at
it too and it realistically it's it's a
it's a situational character meeting um
we've done some collectibles for it it's
never really caught but it doesn't mean
that we're gonna stop we're always
trying to find the best ways to
introduce it in and hopefully you know
when that energy and that excitements
there will be able to meet it with with
with product you know um I but for the
books wise she's all over the books
right now she's a major player in all
the Superman titles right and she has
superwoman I was being coy but yeah cuz
it was a spoiler at some point but not
any mama spoiler it or is it I don't
think so not really not now all right
there you go DC collectible or DC Comics
collectibles entertainment Warner
Brothers movies so check it check it out